안녕하세요. 시도회입니다. 요즘 참
날씨가
들쑥날쑥죽입니다.을 따라 옷을 입고
나가면 바람이 새차게 불어서 춥고
따뜻하게 입고 나가면 금세에 땀이
나는 기운이 찾아오고 말이죠.
오늘은 겨울 끝부터 제가 집으로
들려온 옷가지를 좀 소개해 드리려
합니다. 꽤 오래 고민했던 제품들부터
이슈가 됐던 제품들 그리고 이리저리
손이 잘 갈 것 같은
제품들까지 저의 올해 봄여름을 함께할
친구들을 소개해 드리겠습니다.
처음 소개해 드릴 제품은 EOSS
자크미스와 팀버랜드의 협업으로 출시된
3이 러그 보트 슈즈입니다. 이번에
출시될 것이란 건 진작 알고는
있었는데 사진만 봤을 땐 협업의
느낌이 잘 안 나서 구매할 생각이
없었어요. 그런데 신세계 강남에서
직접 보고 신어 보니까 적당한
자크밋의 감성과이 색감이 마음에
들어서 구매하게 됐습니다. 일단
제품은 티머랜드 3i 보트시즈의
모델을 사용하고 있어요. 색상명은
바나나 옐로우라고 돼 있는데 직접
보면 그 색상명이 사뭇 이해가
됩니다. 자크미스는 시즌과 계절에
맞춰서 팔레트를 다양하게 사용합니다.
이번 시즌 같은 경우에는이 팀버랜드와
같은 쨍한 노란 색감을 자주
사용하더라고요. 이번 시즌 론드가레와
또 새로된 투리스모 가방을 비롯해서
각종 레디트 웨어의이 색감을
사용했습니다.
개인적으로 햇빛에 참 잘 어울리는
색감이라서 봄여름 옷에 포인트로
섞기에 적절하다고
생각해요. 지난주 발매한 자크미스의
썸모 캡슐에도이 노란 색감을 비롯해서
휴양지 느낌 나는 색감의 제품군이
여러 발매됐는데 한번 가까운 매장에서
확인해 보시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
아무튼 다시 신발로 돌아가면 어퍼는
노란색의 소가죽으로 되어 있어서
탄탄합니다. 자크미스의 감성을 느낄
수 있는 디테일은 색감에도 군대군데
박혀 있는데요. 보트 슈즈의 특징인
옆을 둘러싼 신발근에 자크미스 로고가
들어간 메탈 파츠가 있고 아일렛도
로고가 적힌 원기둥과 직육면체
모양으로 되어 있습니다. 이런
기아학적 형태를 사용한 디테일은
자크니스의 컬렉션에서도 여럿 확인할
수가 있는데요. 예를 들어서
투리스모백의 여다지 부분도 네모와
동그라미 론드가의 양끝도 구와
정육면체 스피아치아백의 전체 모양은
네모, 손잡이는 원형으로 되
있습니다. 찾아보니까 자크미스는 이런
원형과 사각형 등을 사용해 건축적
실로엣을 표현해서 흐르는 부드러운
형태와의 대비를 이루고자 한다고
합니다. 저는 사실 팀버랜드를 이번에
처음 신어봤는데 생각보다 굉장히
편하더라고요. 저는 정 사이즈를
갔는데 발볼이 있는 분들이라면 반에서
한 사이즈 크게 가시는게 좋을 것
같습니다.이 신발은 튀어 보이는 첫
인상에 비해서 이곳저곳에 다 잘
어울리더라고요. 오늘 다른 제품들을
소개하면서 계속 신고 있을 예정인데
그래도이 신발과 가장 잘 붙는다고
생각하는 청바지와 함께 신어봤습니다.
다크미스도 캠페인샷에선 연한
베이지색의 바지와 또 시모는
올블랙에도 씻는 것을 보면 꽤나
범용성이 있는 색감이 디자인이라고
생각합니다. 두 번째로 소개해 드릴
제품은 문달의 서머드 나그랑
니트입니다. 옷 좋아하는 분들이라면
아마 공감하실 수도 있는데 저는
다가오는 계절을 기다리면서 아 이번엔
어떤 옷을 이번 봄에 입어보고 싶다
생각하곤 합니다. 이번 봄여름에는
남자 나그랑 니트를 찾고 있었어요.
로고 필요 없이 정말 미니멀한 그
배색 있는 니트요. 그런데 남성복에선
아무리 뒤져봐도 마땅한 걸 찾지
못했습니다. 계속 머리 한 켠에이
나그랑 니트에 대한 탭을 끄지 않고
생각하다가 친구따라 예전에 다녀온
한남동의 문다리라는 브랜드가
생각났어요. 거기서 여성용 나그랑
니트를 봤었는데 디자인이 마음에
들었었거든요. 생각난 김에 찾아보니까
여성북 브랜드이긴 하지만 남자도 입을
수 있는 프리 사이즈가 나왔더라고요.
실책을 보고 괜찮겠다 싶어서 구매하게
됐고 보시다시피 다행히 제게 맞는
사이즈입니다. 두께감도 제가 찾던
여름 소재로 된 얇은 니트예요. 제가
나그랑 맨투맨이 아니라 이런 얇은
니트를 찾고 있었던 이유는 맨투맨은
좀 투박하고 두꺼운 느낌이 강한
반면에 니트 소젠 두께에 따라
유려하면서도 흐르는 느낌을 줄 수
있기에 그렇습니다. 덕분에 이런 편한
반바지와 입어도 잘 어울리고 검정
회색의 배색이 무난해서 대임에도 곧잘
붙더라고요. 이런 하늘하늘한 실루엣이
남성 의류에서 찾기가 쉽지 않은데
개인적으로는 좀 더 다양한 브랜드에서
출시됐으면 하는 바람입니다. 다음
소개해 드릴 건 두 달 전쯤 구매한
비즈빔의 럭색 차콜 컬러
제품입니다.이 제품은 비즈빔에서
꾸준히 출시되는 럭색이라는 제품으로
백팩이라는 명칭으로 출시하는
제품들과의 차이가 있어요. 늘
그렇지는 않지만 백팩은 하단 부분이
레더나 스웨이드 소재로 되어 있고
디자인이 럭색에 비해서 다양하게
나옵니다. 사이즈는 모델마다
상의하지만 럭색은 주로 22L로
출시되고 백팩은 20에서 25L로
나옵니다. 그리고 무엇보다 백팩의
가격이 훨씬 비싸요. 백팩 가격이
럭색의 한 두 배 이상입니다. 근데
그렇다고 럭색의 퀄리티가 막 떨어지진
또요. 럭색도 코디로 되어 있어서
탄탄하면서도 스크래치 등의 강한
편입니다. 그리고 저는 바닥이
가죽으로 되어 있지 않아서 백팩
특유에 편하게 쓸 수 있는 장점을
지닌 점이 마음에 들었어요. 원래 한
4년 전쯤 구매한 포터의 데이팩
제품을 들고 다녔는데 곰미도
난일론이긴 하지만 살짝 흐물거리는
느낌이에요. 그래서 각이 상대적으로
좀 더 잡히는 제품을 찾아다니다가이
제품에 정착하게
됐습니다.이 비즈빔 럭색은 노트북도
넉넉하게 들어가는 사이즈라서 요즘
출근용 가방으로 아주 요하게 사용하고
있습니다. 그다음 소개해 드릴 제품도
가방인데 르메르의 EOSS 시즌 필트
네트백입니다. 지난 24S
시즌에이어서 이번 시즌에도 출시된
제품이에요. 여기서 필트는 1860년
노르망에서 시작된 섬유 전문
브랜드입니다.이 피트와 협업으로
출시한게 네트백으로 사이즈는 미니,
미디움, 라지 총 세 가지로
나왔어요. 저는 그중에 남자가 들기에
적절한 가장 큰 라지 사이즈로
색상명은 마론 글라스입니다.이 이
제품은 가죽 스트랩 때문인지 캐주얼한
룩도 어울리긴 하지만 셔츠류의 복식과
좀 더 잘 어울린다고 생각해요. 지난
24S 시즌 때는 남자가 되게 좀
작다고 생각해서 구매를 하지
않았었는데 생각보다 사이즈감도 괜찮고
무엇보다 주머니가 부족한 봄여름
복장에 요날 듯해서 이번에 구매하게
됐습니다.이 네트백은 무게가 가볍고
부피감이 적어서 휴대가 편리해요.
남녀서 모두 휴대폰 등을 넣는 세컨드
백으로 사용하기에 용이하고 사용할
필요가 없으면 다른 가방에 구겨
넣어도 문제가 없어 좋습니다. 그리고
무엇보다 르메르의 가방 치고 가격이
2, 30만 원대로
합리적입니다. 조금 아쉬운 점이
있다면 여성분들은 모르겠지만이 제일
큰 사이즈인 라지도 남성분들이
크로스로 하기에 스트랩의 길이가 좀
짧습니다. 그리고 네트백 특성상이
사이로 립밤 등의 작은 물건이 빠질
수가 있어요. 그래서 저는 작은
더스트백에다가
빠질 만한 립밤이나 에어팟 등을 따로
넣어 다닙니다. 다음 소개해드릴
제품은 이번 EOSS 유니클로유의
후디드 블루종 블랙 제품입니다. 저는
유니클로유의 제품들을 매번 구매하지는
않지만 항상 보기는 합니다. 그
이유는 유니클로유의 제품들을 보면
르메르의 이전 시즌 디테일을
사용하기도 하고 차후 르메르에 등장할
제품들을 엿볼 수 있는 테스트배드
역할을 하기 때문입니다. 가령
유니클로 유의 17 FW 시즌에 더블
페이스 랩코트라는 제품이 등장했었고
그 바로 다음 르메르의 FW 시즌에
랩코트가
등장했었습니다. 그래서 유니클로에
가서 제품들을 보면 예전 르메르
시즌이 연상이 되기도 하고 차후
르메르 시즌의 이후에 보았을 때
공통점을 찾아보는 재미가 있어요.
이번에 둘러보다가 제 마음을 사로잡은
건 바로이 후디드 블루종이었는데요.
사실 굉장히 단순하고 휘뚜루마두루
입기 좋은 제품입니다. 제가 구매한
건 라지 사이즈인데 팔통에 적당한
벌룸핏 볼륨강과 여유로운 느낌이
마음에 들었어요. 제가 이곳에서 가장
좋아하는 건 바로이
넥라인인데요. 이렇게 목이 높게
올라오는 집업 형태의 자체들의
경우에는 대부분 목에 압박감이 있거나
얼굴이 움직일 때 턱이 닿아서 조금
불편하기도 합니다. 물론 다 방풍을
위한 것이긴 하겠지만 저는이 블루종의
넥라인이 여유로워서 지퍼를 끝까지
올려도 편하게 입을 수 있다는 점이
굉장히 마음에
들었어요. 두께감이 얇아서 요즘같이
하루하루 기온 변화가 큰 시기에 들고
다니기 딱 좋습니다. 저는 안에
셔츠를 입고 아래는 기장에긴
온무플릿스의 반바지를 붙여 봤어요.
이렇게 보니까 몇 년 전에 꽤나
유행하던 그 전형적인 시티보이
스타일의 느낌이 나네요. 블루종은
보니까 가격도 꺾여서 한번 경험해
보셔도 좋을 것 같습니다. 다음은
이번에 꽤나 핫했던 알렉스 조노의
볼캡입니다. 탱꾸로스모의 주중 오후에
갔다가 우연찮게 남아 있길래 구매한
제품이에요. 알렉스 조노는 남화공
출신의 디자이너이자 트레일
러너입니다. 어릴 적에 알렉스
어머니가 옷에 새겨준 글씨에서 영감을
받아서 그가 좋아하는 러닝 용품을
출시하고 있어요. 가장 유명한 로고는
아이디그 러닝인데 이건 진짜 인기가
많은지 바로 품절이 됐고 제가 구매한
건 텐토 익스프레스 해석하면 자신의
발로 걸어다닌다는 의미입니다. 제가
모자가 잘 어울린 편이 아니고 특히
일자책은 더욱 안 어울리는데 이모자는
그래도 깊이 감이 적절해서 마음에
들었어요. 빨간 자수와 전체 갈색의
대비도 좋고 뒤에 달린 어드저스터도
독특하게 끈으로 되어 있는 점이
지갑을
열었습니다. 매치로 되어 있어 시원해
여름에도 쉬 손이 갈 것 같은
모자입니다. 마지막 제품은 르메르의
EOSS 시즌 데님 트러커
재켓입니다. 르메르에서 이번 시즌
가장 기다렸던 제품 중 하나예요.
개인적으론 르메르의 EOS 쇼는
이전의 것들에 비해 그렇게 임팩트
있게 느껴지진 않았습니다. 르메르라는
브랜드 특성상 비슷한 제품들이 시즌을
거듭해 출시되긴 하지만
특히나는 아 또 똑같은 거 하는구나
싶었어요. 그런데 막상 제품들을
실제로 보고 입어 보니까 역설적으로
제가 가장 많은 제품을 구매한 시즌
중 하나가 됐습니다. 쇼와 실물을
봤을 때 느끼는 차이가 컸지만 그런
와중에 둘 다 마음에 들었던 제품은
바로이
자켓이었어요. 적당히 크롭하면서
르메르 특유에 워크웨어스러운 느낌을
주는 제품입니다.
개인적으로 르메르의 데님 자켓 시리즈
중어 자켓처럼 큰 플랫폼 포켓이
들어간 제품은 제 구매 대상은 딱히
아닙니다. 그 이유는 그런 초어
자켓이라면 데니보다는 몰스킨이나 다른
소재로 된 거에 더 선호하기
때문인데요. 하지만이 자켓은
르메레트의 무거운 데님 소재로 되어
있으면서 이에 잘 어울리는 디자인이
합쳐졌다고 생각합니다. 하나 아쉬운게
있다면 저는 옆심을 따라서 히든으로
리포켓이 있을 것이라 기대했는데
가슴하게 보이는 두 개의 포켓을
제외하고는 따로
없더라고요. 그리고 사이즈가 참
어려웠습니다.이 제품이 총기장은
크롭면서 8기장은 또 인심좋게 길게
나왔어요. 그래서 46부터 50까지
다양하게 고민하다가 딱 중간인 48로
결정하게 됐습니다.이 제품은
쇼에서처럼 데임 셋업으로 입으면 참
좋겠지만 저는 르메르바즈가 더 있기
때문에 데닝 패츠까지는 구매하지
않았습니다. 좀 어두운 색감의
청인지라서 검정 슬렉스와도 잘 붙을
것 같고 제가 입은 베이지나 카키와
같은 전형적인 치노 팬츠와도 잘
어울리는 제품입니다. 크로판 기장을
활용해서 셔츠 등의 기장 레이어링을
집에서 혼자 해 보기도 했는데
아무래도 좀 깔끔한 제품이라서 그런지
괜히 잘못했다가는 옷의 분위기에 맞지
않은 깔롱을 부리는 꼴이 되더라고요.
그냥 힌티에 걸치거나 제가 입은
것처럼 셔츠 위에 툭 입는게 가장 잘
어울린다고
생각합니다. 요즘 업로드 일자가 좀
불규칙해서 참 죄송한 마음입니다. 좀
지연된 이유를 간단히 설명드리면 일단
업무는 늘 있고 늘 바쁩니다. 하지만
이걸 시작한 이상 제 시간을
쪼개보자고 마음 먹었기 때문에 이건
뭐 어쩔 수 없는 거 같고요. 그리고
계속 주변으로부터 추천받았던
애니메이션을 최근에 하나 시작했는데
그거에 완전
빠져버렸었습니다. 애니메이션은 많이들
보셨을 진격의 거인이고 90판 없는
전 시즌에 한 열흘 만에 다 본 것
같아요. 그리고 무엇보다 어떤 걸
지금 나는 담아내고 싶은가에 대한
고민이 있었습니다. 쌓아 놓은 주제는
많은데 진정 내가 내켜서 해야 속도도
붙고 제 언어도 잘 담기더라고요.
그래도 다행인 건 5월 달에 계획
중인 것들이 몇몇 분들이 요청 주셨던
내용임과 동시에 제가 해보고 싶었던
이야기인지라 4월보다는 좀 낫지
않을까 조심슬의 예상인 봅니다.
속도만큼이나 이야기도 잘 준비해
보도록 할게요. 오늘 제 이야기는
여기까지입니다. 감사합니다.